we do have a voicemail number it's two
one nine two david p here is a voicemail
which touches on a number of sensitive
issues number one it involves pats
middle name number two it involves
Keurig eight the most recent scandal
involving producer Pat Forde ripping
through the David Pakman show and that
involves former David Pakman show
producer Louis all wrapped into one
short voicemail take a listen to this
say what's going on with Louis
we all miss Lewis but you know what you
know Pat can't say enough about Pat he's
great he's got a scandal under his belt
right handle you know we called Patrick
Steve Ford reason revealed is Patrick
Constantin boards and I understand and
you'll like them as vegan tack you know
I like taps we all like Pat and so all
the best to Lewis and we missed them but
Pat has come into his own and it's great
to have passed halogen do you feel Pat
as though the keurig situation is a
scandal that you've weathered or do you
not even agree that it's a scandal I
think I got through it I mean everyone's
going to have some skeletons in their
past their had to confront it has to
mean this morning yeah
[Laughter]
okay so anyway that that's that's one
one perspective do you feel that you
were most identified by the audience as
keurig Pat or vegan Pat at this I like
vegan producer Pat VP that's my favorite
and also it was nice I only had to pay
this caller $20 Yeah right very
relatively affordable okay on the bonus
show today
Tommy Larenz nightly show has been
pulled for a week after her comments
about being pro-choice I will talk to
you about the new global ranking of
happiness but also why some of these
rankings can be a little problematic and
I will lastly tell you about a major
revelation regarding Boston sports that
FBI director James Comey made during his
Monday FBI hearing all of those stories
and more on the bonus show sign up at
david pakman.com slash membership
there's a coupon code it's I voted 17 it
you a big league discount off of
membership I encourage you to sign up
and use it